tell me something that you love about  where you live whataburger  oh okay great um tell me about it you  wanna go right now yeah let's go i'm  ready  just no just uh tell me about it you're  gonna love whataburger ben oh it's the  best what makes it the best wherever you  are there's a whataburger yeah it's  always right there  okay and then when you get there what do  you like about it what do you get  whatever you want  you could order whatever you want ben  right  but there are a lot of places like that  so let's say  there's a mcdonald's a burger king a  sonic and a whataburger all lined up  which one do you go to water  right right why  [Applause]